could you imagine Juan Pablos [ __ ]
recording that [ __ ] in the studio that
[ __ ] mic must have been dirtiest [ __ ]
alright pop hit God dead you are
spitting all over the [ __ ] hey what is
going on YouTube now dealing with bad
drivers on a daily basis has to be one
of the most annoying things on earth
because that is one thing that no matter
what race creed or religion that
everybody can relate to is that we hate
bad drivers because I can't tell you how
many times I wanted to take the time of
Hawking just you know Shh
alright at the back of somebody's tires
and they just ride off a bridge what but
I would like for them to survive because
I'm not a murderer
I will you know but if somebody else
would you know man so if you ever needed
someone to express these types of
feelings and emotions that are going
through your head when you experience
these types of drivers you already know
[Music]
use your signal you know that damn thing
next to your steering wheel is like the
thing you used to wipe the windshield
it's for your [ __ ] turn signal oh
what's that you ask
it's for you to signal to me so I can
know when the [ __ ] your attorney yeah
how else are we supposed to know that
you were gonna slam your [ __ ] brakes
and hit that sharp ass [ __ ] right
turn like you delivering our heart to an
organ donor [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
going oh that's right because we're
supposed to read your thought they know
what you're gonna be doing [ __ ] do we
look like Professor X my x-men powers
are telling me you're a dumb [ __ ] and
when they nearly caused an accident when
they [ __ ] up tell me what happens they
have the nerve I said the none of them
come in hi oh myself
not to get mad at you like EU [ __ ] I
wish a [ __ ] would do you know
that you are the cause of the problem
that for every action there is a
reaction that if you slam your brakes
and make a sharp turn without a signal
there is a good chance that somebody
just might slam into the back of you how
do you sleep at night you evil
[ __ ] yeah you look like the type
that sleep on a bed of crime puppies
that's right yeah you sick [ __ ] oh and
don't even get me started this right
here when people get mad at you for not
letting them into the lane when they
didn't use their signal do you know why
people are letting you in because we
didn't know that you want to come in
because you did not use your sake
personally I would gladly let you in my
friend
only if you signal so I know that you
want to come in so don't you think that
there's a higher chance that you could
get into my lane if you use that blinky
blinky things that gives me a warning
that your wants to come in cuz if
there's a decent gather and yo once they
get in david so well let you go and i
know what some of you are going to say
well didn't you see me lean into your
lane could you already tell that i was
gonna come in [ __ ] number one there's a
high probability that we did not see you
can probably he was in a blind spot get
dumb number two if you're gonna be all
pushy like that what the [ __ ] with
somebody let you win your rude ass
[ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i know you you probably
that dude they want to have sex with
your girlfriend all the time even when
she don't want and you're gonna push
your [ __ ] buttons nobody's no
[ __ ] like me supposed to read
you and [ __ ] but Professor X you must
think we missed clear wrong the
terrorcons are telling me you're a [ __ ]
yeah bumbaclot when we are in traffic
stop honking your damn horn did you know
that it's a scientific fact that nobody
is going to move faster
you constantly honk your horn that's why
I said science I don't even know [ __ ]
about Stein equals MC [ __ ] you what do
you think just because you did this that
everybody was gonna be like that know
what never junk your horn no [ __ ] you
ain't special you especially still
listen I understand that you're angry
traffic is [ __ ] annoying you got
somewhere to go maybe you're hungry
maybe you gotta take a piss but you piss
it everybody else off does it help the
situation the person in front of you can
do absolutely nothing to relieve your
anger because just like you we are also
stuck in traffic word stop act like
everybody else on gridlock wants to be
here except for you member us with just
me you think everybody else in traffic
is saying to themselves well I wanted to
feed my kids dinner but [ __ ] those
little shits I'm stuck in traffic
can we go even further and talk about
the people who text and drive oh you
look a little guilty really what the
hell is going on in your life that that
person can not wait 15 minutes for you
to text them back later cuz you really
have to think to yourself it's in fact
important because I guarantee you that
it usually isn't and the only reason why
you wanna text this person back is
number one you're bored as [ __ ] when
you're driving or number two is somebody
you're trying to [ __ ] and you just can't
keep your dick in place or your vagina
lock is that how it works I don't know
[ __ ] about women I don't give a toucan
but [ __ ] Sam who the hell it is on
the other line it could be President
Obama himself and you could tell POTUS
to hold the hell own up mmm David I uh
I have something important to tell you
well mr. POTUS you are can wake us I
derive it and I know what you're gonna
say don't lie you don't text and drive
they act like a hypocrite no I actually
don't text and drive I might see a text
on my phone from the car mount unlike
you you unsafe not giving a [ __ ] about
somebody else's life ya Rhino butt
[ __ ] [ __ ] they [ __ ]
bit and by the way not only are you
endangering other people's lives while
you're texting on your phone and you're
not looking at the road above you every
time you are at a stoplight what happens
when you're texting you forget that
you're in a car driving so when the
light turns green you never go you are
the reason there is traffic online and
I'm just gonna put this out there
[ __ ] YouTube is sensitive it's fun I
don't give a [ __ ]
hey you texting and driving is dangerous
cuz you might [ __ ] somebody else up you
could hurt yourself as much as you want
I don't give two [ __ ] about you but if
you have enough [ __ ] sense to know
and care about somebody else's life get
the [ __ ] off your phone do I have more
to talk about when it comes to bad
drivers of course I do
but I can't I can't do this anymore
because I'm lightheaded from all the
yelling [ __ ] [ __ ] you bad drivers hey
what's going on YouTube so I am actually
a my bed and doing this video like a
crazy person haha
yeah but so you know how I told you guys
last week that we were going to do
videos from Sunday Monday Tuesday
Wednesday I'm actually gonna flip that
up because I realized how crazy that
[ __ ] was we are going to be doing videos
the other way around so starting from
Thursday Friday Saturday and Sunday you
guys are going to get four videos from
now on meaning Thursday through Friday
through Saturday you will get an lol and
then on Sunday you get your regular
viewing which is your regular funny ass
videos whether that could be some
articles whatever you guys submit
whatever you guys you want to be
involved in you guys are gonna get that
so remember Thursday through Sunday
new videos Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday yes I will see you guys there the
pervert lives Oh [ __ ] get me started
but I would like within this hour nobody
Oh get that [ __ ] kid in kindergarten
that would always kind of scene when
they didn't get it that way drop it to
the goddamn floor spitting in a [ __ ]
circle till you got your damn way [ __ ]
will unless you Magneto when you could
toss these [ __ ] cars aside we ain't
going nowhere